في تحدي مثير تداول رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو لليوتيوبر وهي تاكل
50 بيضه في 35 دقيقه نشرت في قناتها على
اليوتيوب الفيديو لا قد تفاعل واسعا من
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي معبرين عن
استغرابهم من تصرفها
[موسيقى]
خطف الطفله الجزائريه الاضواء بعدما اطلق
الاتحاد الافريقي لكره القدم كاف نداء
للعثور عليها بعدما ظهرت خلال المباراه في
كاس الامم الافريقيه للمحليين التي تقام
في الجزائر ونشر الكاف عبر حسابه الرسميه
على تويتر مقطع فيديو للطفله وهي ترقص على
الانغام الموسيقيه خلال حضورها المباراه
وغردكاس ايضا ساعدونا في العثور على هذه
الفتاه رائعه لدينا مفاجاه لها
[موسيقى]
لا تؤذني في ابنتي واول رزقي مقطع فيديو
تم تداوله على رقم على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لابن يوصي زوجه ابنته بكلمات
مؤثره ابكت جميع الحضور نتابع
وابنته وحبيبه قلبي
واول رزقي
ودليل الى الخير
[موسيقى]
لما علمت ان الولد
يحمل اسم ابيه
حملتني كلي
سبقت كل الودان
[موسيقى]
بوصيه من امها
ان تشتهر في طاعتك
والا تعصيلك امره ولا تفشي لك سرا ولا
تحزن عند فرحك ولا تفرح عند حزنك الى اخر
ما توصي به الام الصالحه